history's vikings will surely be
remembered as one of the most sweeping
historical epics of all time
a whole lot happened over the course of
the show's six seasons and keeping track
of dates can be a little tricky
which is why we're breaking down the
entire vikings timeline
we know that the first major on-screen
event in vikings happened in 793
because it's based on an actual raid
that took place that year in history
the first real-life viking attack on the
anglo-saxon soil
actually unfolded four years earlier
when three
longboats landed on the coast of wessex
and murdered the king's reeve
but this raid was on a different level
when a band of bloodthirsty vikings
plundered saint cutberg's church on
lindisfarne
and slaughtered the defenseless monks
they found there they surely made their
presence known throughout england
that's exactly what happens on history's
vikings
though in the tv show the lindisfarne
raid is led by ragnar lothbra
a simple farmer with lofty ambitions
ragnar gained the respect of his people
by uniting them with a common cause
when he returned from england with
foreign riches and athelstan
a monk slave who would later become a
trusted friend interest in returning to
the saxon kingdoms was high
however ragnar's chieftain earl
harrelson wasn't thrilled with ragnar's
rising popularity
and attempted to have him killed when
his assassination attempt failed he
accepted ragnar's offer of a duel to the
death
which of course he lost armed with the
knowledge he gained from atherstan
ragnar began organizing a large-scale
attack and the age of the viking saxon
wars began
ragnar sailed westward again around the
year 800
this time with the aid of his last
remaining superior king horik of denmark
their combined forces landed further
south this time
coming ashore not in northumbria but in
the kingdom of wessex
their plundering of the monastery at
winchester quickly got the attention of
king ekber
who was eager to speak with ragnar when
the ruler of wessex discovered that
ragnar simply wanted to create a farming
settlement for his people
they got to talking terms unfortunately
discussions were derailed when
ragnar received word that earl borg had
attacked his home category in his
absence
dealing with jarl borg wasn't exactly
straightforward but he ultimately
outsmarted the swedish usurper with the
help of his former wife lagether
and now grown son bjern his elation was
short-lived however
boric soon arrived informing ragnar that
eckbert attacked the fledgling norse
settlement after he left
with lacatha's help ragnar and horik
returned to wessex though the latter's
increasing paranoia over ragnar's
natural leadership
cost the norsemen the battle the king
attempted to have ragnar killed upon
their return
but loyal friend floki tipped him off
which resulted of course
in horuk's brutal death afterwards
ragnar took the crown for himself
the newly crowned king ragnar returned
to wessex in around the year 803
ready to reopen a dialogue with the
saxon kingdom's learned leader
athelstan had him well versed in the
ways of christianity by that point
and he would ultimately form a bond with
ekbert based on mutual respect
in order to seal his resurrected
alliance with wessex ragnar was tasked
with helping ekberg's ally
princess clintharth take the crown of
neighboring kingdom
mercia from her uncle as the most
sexually charged character in the show
by far
it seemed inevitable that quinthrath
would eventually pursue ragnar
though we did not get to see it actually
happen on screen it is heavily implied
that the two did the d
eventually quindriff gives birth to a
baby boy magnus and proclaims that he is
ragnar's son
i think you may know him ragnar lothbrok
ragnar never acknowledged this to be
true but nobody could doubt his
dedication to the viking
cause as he would later die fighting
with his norse brethren
next comes the great siege of paris
based on real events that occurred in
the mid to late 9th century
spanning the 8th 9th and 10th episodes
of season 3 this made for one of the
most engrossing battles of the entire
series
a challenge like nothing they'd faced
before ragnar and his huge viking fleet
struggled to breach the walls of paris
an island city at the time both he and
his son beyond suffered serious injuries
and appeared as though ragnar would
succumb to his
he arranged a meeting with the franks
but when they offered him gold
he refused he told them he was dying and
wanted to be baptized before he passed
ragnar requested that he be buried in
the city and his relieved enemies agreed
which of course was a terrible mistake
the sly viking king leapt from his
coffin once inside the city's cathedral
slaying the bishop of paris in front of
the terrified emperor charles
it was ragnar's cunning that led to the
successful sack of paris but when he
returned to the frankish stronghold a
few years later
he came up against a formidable foe in
the form of his own brother
rolo volunteered to stay behind and keep
charge of a viking camp near paris
after the first raid and when ragnar
returned home for the winter
charles decided to reach out the meek
emperor offered rolo land
riches and his daughter's hand in
marriage if he switched sides and
protected paris from further raids
having already caught a glimpse of
princess jila during the siege
rollo gladly accepted the emperor's
terms something his bride-to-be was far
from thrilled about
rollo had a very hard time winning the
headstrong princess over
though his actions during the second
siege of paris proved where his
loyalties lay
using his knowledge of viking warfare to
prepare the city for an attack
rollo urged the franks to build more
ships ragnar's rabid forces gained the
upper hand at first but the battle took
a turn when rollo killed one of his
own soldiers for cowardice and delivered
an inspiring speech to his shaken men
the vikings were forced to retreat and
rollo returned to paris as a hero
a defeated and shamed ragnar sailed away
and began his years of exile
ragnar lothbrok vanished for years after
his humiliating loss to the friends
when he returned to catagette around a
decade after his disappearance he was no
longer the strong fearsome warrior the
western world once knew amass
but it didn't matter since none of his
sons were willing to fight him for the
throne
he announced that he planned on
returning to england but his son
ivar the boneless was the only one of
the brood willing to journey with him
ragnar's crippled son was still living
in the considerable shadows of his
battle-hardened brothers at that stage
but this father-son trip across the
north sea would be the start of his
journey to greatness
the year was approximately 8 17 when
ragnar and ivar arrived in wessex their
fleet mostly decimated by storms
they were soon captured by ragnar's old
frenemy king ekberg who just couldn't
bring himself to kill the famous viking
ragnar suggested that he be sent up to
northumbria where king ayla would deal
with him
he convinced ekbert that all he had to
do was let ivar go
so he could tell of what happened and
his sons would then seek revenge against
the northumbrians
not wessex ragnar was then carted off to
ayla who tossed him into a pit of
venomous snakes
bringing his reign to an end his second
wife al slaw
met her end around the same time
murdered by his first wife
lagatha a year after the valkyries
carried ragnar off to valhalla his sons
returned to england to exact their
revenge on the man who killed him
they arrived in northumbria with a force
of around 4 000 vikings
overwhelming the underprepared saxons
ayla was brought to the snake pit where
ragnar died
and put to an even more horrific death
by beyond
ragnaros firstborn subjected the king to
northumbria to the dreaded blood eagle
a grisly method of execution mentioned
in norse sagas that involves cutting
open the back of a still breathing
victim
and pulling the lungs out into the shape
of wings
when ragnar's sons were done taking
their bloody revenge on king ayla they
had yet
another saxon monarch to attend to king
ekbert of wessex released ivar on the
condition that he returned to kataga
and explained that it was ayla who
executed ragnar not him
what ekberg didn't know is that ragnar
had secretly instructed ivar to seek
revenge on him too
the famous viking knew he was a spent
force but he also knew that if he
allowed himself to be killed by saxons
his boys would come down on them with
the force of thor's hammer
it was part of a larger and bolder
strategy according to ragnar
and it worked ekberg took his own life
after ragnar's son stormed his villa
the great heathen army had achieved its
prime objectives at this stage and those
leading it wanted different things
tempers began to flare as the sons of
ragnar discussed plans for the future in
front of their people
some wanted to stay and farm while
others wanted to explore new places
but ivar was determined to keep the
great army together for more conquest
as he attempted to win the crowd over to
his cause his already strained
relationship with seaguird reached its
breaking point
siegert mocked ivar for not being a real
man and it was the last thing he did
ivor killed him with a throwing axe
right in front of their brothers
bjern had just set foot in spain for the
first time when he learned of his dad's
death from odin who appeared to all five
of ragnar's sons in separate visions to
break the news
the mediterranean was the furthest that
his people had ever been at that stage
with ayla and ekberg both dealt with
bjorn returned to southern europe to
fulfill his destiny
it was around the year 819 when his
fleet arrived at sicily
he agreed to work as a bodyguard to
byzantine admiral euphemias but when he
learned that his new boss was under the
command of a great arab leader in north
africa
the yearn became interested in him
instead after traveling across the
desert by camel caravan
the urine and his companion hofdan was
greeted by emir
ziadat allah who seemed interested in
trade the norseman quickly discovered
that he wasn't a man you crossed however
when they sat down to feast with the
emir they realized that euphemius was
absent from the meal
because he was the meal bjorn escaped
from the cannibal warlord's camp
under the cover of a sandstorm and
sailed back to katagat
to deal with ivar who had claimed the
throne in his absence
floki was at the head of the great
heathen army alongside ragnar's sons
and like them he needed a new adventure
after avenging his old friend's murder
as bjern broke new ground in the
mediterranean and north africa
the famous shipwright took a long boat
in the opposite direction
he didn't have a specific location in
mind but he ended up discovering a whole
new land
floki had given himself up to the gods
at this stage so when he came ashore in
what would become known as iceland and
set eyes upon the island's stunning
natural wonders he believed he had been
led to asgard
intent on settling in the land of the
gods floki returned to catagout
and recruited a group of intrepid
travelers he found a new purpose as the
head of the icelandic settlement but
eventually became disheartened when
infighting among the group led to a
series of murders he would eventually
retreat into a cave on the island
convinced that he had found negate to
helheim
norse mythology's underworld what he
found was far
worse a cross floki was such a staunch
believer in the old gods that he
murdered ragnar's monk friend
ethelstan in cold blood so when he came
to the realization that christians had
already been on iceland he was
borderline hysterical
the viking was half laughing half crying
when the cave complex began to collapse
on him
after his travels around the
mediterranean and sahara bjern came home
and set his sights on becoming the first
king of all norway
the idea was proposed by king olaf who
brought the country's rulers together so
they could vote on who should lead them
bjern had it in the bag until king
harold swooped in
cheating him out of the crown this took
place around 8 20
a terrible year to be biuran ironside it
started out well enough
being that he managed to retake category
from his brother ivar but he lost the
big election
and his beloved mother was killed soon
after the famous shield made in lagatha
died in a manner unbefitting of her
fierce reputation
stabbed to death in a dark muddy street
by fitzer
ragnar's most troubled son fitzhurk
developed a drug problem after the death
of his lover thora at ivar's behest
he was hallucinating badly when he
murdered an unsuspecting lagatha
mistaking her for ivar in serpent form
show creator michael hurst told
entertainment tonight
her death is a huge tragedy i even cried
when i was writing it
lacketha actress catherine winick
praised the show's creator for her
funeral in the show
i don't think i can top the way lagertha
goes and her funeral she admitted that
watching those events play out on screen
wasn't easy
she said during comic con 2020 seeing
lagatha transitioning over to valhalla
was a bittersweet moment in a lot of
ways
after being ousted from category by
beyond ivar went into exile
and spent time traveling the famous silk
road the viking encountered all manner
of people and cultures along the
legendary trading route
which ultimately led him to nav gorod
seated the grand prince of russ olek
the christian zealot was instantly
intrigued by the exiled norsemen
and he would reveal to ivar that he
intended to reclaim his people's
ancestral homeland in scandinavia
in approximately the year 821 oleg and
ivar marched on tandra home of king
howard
despite their feud over the election
beyond turned up to help harold defend
his land
which turned out to be a fatal mistake
the first part of the final season of
vikings came to an end
with ivar running a blade through bjorn
it seemed like a wound that nobody could
recover from
and that turned out to be the case but
before beyond died
he donned his armor and inspired his
people to victory one last time
when the roosts arrived at category they
assumed that it's fearsome
warrior king was dead when bjorn
appeared on horseback
and took three arrows to the body
without falling the terrified invaders
started to believe he couldn't be killed
michael hurst told entertainment tonight
he does something quite extraordinary at
the end of his life
he saves his country and puts himself in
the pantheon of the great heroes of the
vikings
ivar wrapped up his personal redemption
arc when he freed young russ
prince igor from the grip of his
maniacal uncle oleg but he still had
professional ambitions
the people of category reluctantly
welcomed him home but ivor found himself
unable to settle
knowing that there was still one saxon
kingdom left standing
he and fitzer convinced an equally bored
harold that taking wessex was the only
thing left for them to do
and so they set sail for england with a
viking army at their backs
alfred the son of ekbert's daughter and
athelston was now running the show on
wesson's
the real alfred is the only english
monarch to have been given the epithet
the great largely because his was the
only anglo-saxon kingdom that withstood
the viking onslaught
history shows that he utilized cunning
tactics and brute force to repel his
norse foes
but in the show the war is won when a
random west saxon soldier pops up in
front of ivar
and stabs him with zero resistance
ivar's death baffled and angered fans in
equal measure
but alex hugh anderson said in an
interview with entertainment tonight
it felt like the most natural thing in
the world i really wanted him to go out
in a completely different way than
everybody
else according to history viking
explorer leif erikson
likely made land in north america long
before christopher columbus crossed the
atlantic
north sagas and archaeological finds
suggest that eriksen set out from
scandinavia some 500 years before
columbus was even born
arriving in the so-called new world in
the year 1000.
eriksen is a main character in michael
hurst's
sequel series vikings valhalla but the
showrunner always planned on visiting
north america and vikings
hearst told collider i knew that the
ending would be the discovery of america
in newfoundland in the show it's uber
who led the first group of viking
settlers to north america
they stumbled across greenland first but
ragnar's son and his family fled the
barely hospitable island
amid a violent squabble over whale meat
it was roughly the year 8
21 when uber finally set eyes on the
golden land
he lost his step-daughter on the voyage
but uber found a long-lost friend when
he got there
floki survived the cave-in and sailed to
newfoundland
making a home for himself among the
accepting natives things almost went
ahri when a greedy viking murdered an
innocent local
but uber put the offender to death and
restored peace
the viking saga came to an end with uber
and floki watching the sunset from a
pristine american beach
discussing the gods and reminiscing
about the man who started it all
ragnar check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one